oh
hey everybody
hope you're having a nice day
it's uh
it's just turned into a generally
frustrating
kind of day
for me
not like terrible
it wasn't awful but like
[Music]
just a lot of uh
frustration
uh carowind um
unfortunately um isn't feeling well and
won't be joining us uh this evening uh
as a mod in the chat
um she did wish that she could be here i
got permission from her to share that
with everybody but
yeah some things are just
uh
what's my head cannon that happened to
ace between survival and the tv movie
i'm not
i'm not that kind of head canon person
generally if i do head canon it's gonna
be to cover
um
yeah it's gonna be to connect to
existing dots not to come up with an
entire
separate bit of uh of canon
that's just not really
it's not really how my head works
love to carolyn thank you i will pass
that along
i think she'll appreciate it
uh that is not something i needed to
know
ms wicked wolf because i'm old enough to
remember when that happened so
if he could not
that that actually
be great
oh
also had a rough day had my first
twitter argument about racism
nothing productive ever comes from
arguing on twitter
i mean it doesn't i try not to do it i
hit it sometimes uh i end up doing that
but
eh
i really try not to
thoughts on a shod returning for uh the
centenary special i okay
i don't know what to feel about any
of the
um
specific
things that were in that trailer because
a number of them as individual elements
i'm like ooh
but
like my biggest criticism of chibnall
from his last lengthy stretch was from
flex and everything was freaking
overstuffed to hell and so i'm just
seeing the sheer amount of things that
we've gotten teased
and uh and knowing how many plot threads
there are still to wrap up and they and
we haven't seen joe martin show up in
this material like um
i'm i'm nervous like in a vacuum the
idea of bringing back a shot i am down
with because he's a great concept and a
creepy character and had a lot more
potential than was used but like
cramming one more thing
into that special i don't know
i
i really don't
just checking can we freely talk about
doctor who spoilers um i'm gonna say yes
but that's partially because like
there's almost nothing to spoil
in the latest special like unless you're
worried about being spoiled on the story
itself
like but it has almost
nothing substantive happen i mean i
think it's far more spoilery to talk
about the trailer i think plenty of
people saw that but
we re-watched warriors of the deep
yesterday let's say another issue with
gypsy devils why ditch the flippers i
forgot about the flippers
i heard kevin conroy was gay uh
the batman animated series batman oh is
he
i was unaware i mean cool that's fine
thoughts on nissa and tegan officially
being a couple is that official
did i miss that where was that confirmed
i missed something
uh
have i seen smiling friends
i don't think so just because i don't
know what it is
i asked re the trailer but most people
know by now yeah yeah
excluding the two already confirmed what
classic companions would you most like
to see return not necessarily in the
centenary but in any future story
if they're ever going to pull the
trigger on bringing back susan which i'm
a little skeptical on they need to do it
soon because they should they should
have the same actress reprise the role
um
romano would be the other big one i
suppose
um i mean
i'm not saying they should actually do
this
but if they really wanted to pull some
nonsense they could bring adrick back as
a villain
i'm hydrating with lemon raspberry
crystal light fortified by vodka very
refreshing that sounds delightful
uh i hope you're not mad at what i said
about your will smith video i don't
remember
right now
uh black cover 95 so
probably best not to bring it up again
if you're asking what i'm drained about
today like definitely not that because i
don't even remember what you said
supreme omega thank you very much for
the super chat i hope you're well
question is all of 90s comics bad i know
you have your criticisms but there is
good stuff for me the 90s is the golden
age of dc legacy heroes
um no
not all of 90s comics are bad like i had
a podcast for a while called 90s comics
retrial um where i just went through my
own collection of 90s comics which is
very marvel heavy uh not a lot of dc
stuff but i just went through it and i'm
like okay is this actually good now most
of the stuff that's bad in the 90s are
bad and incredibly 90s ways is there
still some good stuff yeah
oh yeah i love i will stand by
and defend
stuff like the max
um spiderman 2099
heck first dozen issues or so of spawn
i'll defend like there's good stuff that
happened in the 90s
there was just
you know the major trends were
they were
they were so bad
oh my goodness
michael anderson doyle thank you for
uh renewing on the membership much
appreciated
listen to your babylon 5 podcast today i
hope you're enjoying that
uh question have you ever heard of the
spider-man villain called the wolf
spider who's an insane murder version of
peter parker sorry
uh for the misspell uh only heard a
spoke um
no not familiar with that one
but i mean
given how many clones the guy has i
don't suppose it's that surprising
huh
oh i was i was i was wondering when that
was gonna come up the uh
the fact that ezra miller got arrested
again
today
oh
my gosh
so
the fact that they got arrested
this
like they they haven't even cleared up
the last bunch of stuff
that happened and they get arrested
again for assault this time they threw a
chair and it hit somebody in the head
warner brothers
has got to be scrambling right now
trying to figure out what to do with the
flash because
um with the
um
with the merger with discovery now
finalized this is actually a point in
time where
major management
and the top brass at warner brothers
might actually change
be forced out or new people brought in
and
things going this badly
uh
would be a reason to do so so the people
who are there currently if they are at
all interested in keeping their jobs
they are probably doing
a ton of brain calculus trying to figure
out like look
we have no good options is very clear
now that they're not going to stop
getting in trouble or at least that is
uh significantly less likely than it
ever was previously
um
but
in addition to that
like
the other option is to do massive
reshoots on the flash which is super
expensive and that looks really bad too
so they just they don't
have
good options and as i said in the video
before this is not me expressing
sympathy
screw them but
john vinyls thank you very much for the
super chat i appreciate that imagine if
a modern remake of aliens ripley and
vasquez were a couple
um
i mean maybe i personally don't think
ripley benefited from a romantic story
at all i just scrap it
but
that's me in scrapping uh
scrapping
um you know romantic stories in most
cases anyway so
hey
has a protagonist actor ever been
replaced post shooting
um
i'm not sure
i'm
protagonist actors have been replaced
mid-shooting
uh the very first
um
back to the future
uh didn't have michael j fox in it they
started shooting
uh with another actor whose name
suddenly escapes me
um and it was they were several weeks
into
filming
when they realized this just is not
working and they brought in michael j
fox very suddenly but
that
filming wasn't done
when that happened similarly with um
[Music]
with aragorn and the lord of the rings
that was originally another actor and
they did a couple of weeks of shooting
and they realized
this isn't working and we cast too young
so they brought in viggo mortensen to be
aragorn very last minute
so
i but i can't
i can't think of a time
when
a movie was done and the lead
was reshot
um
supporting characters sometimes like
somebody mentioned in the chat uh all
the money in the world
or
um army of the dead like that can happen
with uh with a supporting character but
the lead reshooting the lead afterwards
like
that that's not really a thing so far as
i know
because at that point like
and the other thing is
all right actually let me back up
if
yeah in this
big if
if
the
movie and the studio has if the movie is
so good
and the in the studio has so much faith
that like is such a good movie it's such
a good story it's so well directed
everything else is falling into place
it's like such a good movie
that might nudge them towards something
maybe as drastic as recasting
the lead however if they don't have that
degree of confidence
in the finished product then it's a sunk
cost issue which is that
they they will ultimately be better off
releasing it as is rather than spending
a ton of more money on it than they
already have
and keep in mind they have more expenses
coming up the marketing machine hasn't
really geared up on this yet and now at
this point even if ezra miller manages
to stay out of trouble they're not going
to be able to start dropping teaser
trailers for
months
at this point because they they need to
wait for this to lapse out of the news
cycle
ah
paddington was re-voiced when they
decided colin firth's voice didn't work
and brought in ben wish
voice work is really a different thing
though i mean shrek was almost finished
with chris farley when they brought in
um mike myers like voice work is a
different thing because you don't have
to redo
all of the animation from scratch maybe
redo a little lip sync
depending on how you do that
but
question if it was extreme enough do you
think
they can make a movie to take
uh do you think
oh hold on let me try this again if it
was extreme enough do you think
they'd can the movie and take the
financial hit and avoid the bad pr
uh like if they murdered someone
okay if we're going fully hypothetical
here
if
the lead actor of a movie i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna
say specifically ezra miller in this
case because then it feels like i'm
speculating about what they may or may
not do in the future i don't want to go
there but let's just like talk in a
vacuum
if a major tentpole film an expensive
film is due to come out in about a year
and the lead
is arrested
for murder
yes they probably have to shelve it
now depending on the nature of the movie
they might come back and try to revive
it in a different form
or
you know
dump it to streaming in five years but
yeah they would they would uh they'd
probably the stu they being the studio
in this case they'd probably
um put the movie on ice for something
like that
me
uh
oh
jon vinyls thank you again for the super
chat uh how was it that warner brothers
had completely fallen apart since
2013. well okay
a conf
confluence of things warner brothers um
did a couple of
did a couple of miscalcula well i mean
you could go back further than that
warner brothers really started having a
lot of trouble
around about initially when they merged
with aol back in the early 2000s but you
know what let's skip over that you want
to say around 2013 or on
so initially
um
it was the gradual restructuring
um of
their plans for films they did what
felt like
a very safe
bet
um and what probably on paper made a lot
of sense
which was their biggest moneymakers were
these big tentpole
films films
tentpole films
and they made the decision like okay
we're gonna stop with this mid-budget
stuff we're gonna stop
with 30 40 50 60 70 million dollar
movies we're not doing that anymore
we're only doing movies with
um
100 million dollar plus budgets
uh
and we're only going to
um engage with
franchises that are doing well for us so
at the time they made that decision
they basically said flat out the only
things we are going to make
are dc superhero films
lego
movie films because the lego movie had
just come out they had a bunch of
sequels planned
and
uh
things related to harry potter because
at that point the
formal uh franchise had finished the
thing the actual adaptations of the
books but they were planning the
fantastic beasts movies
what happened then
was all three of those stumbled
now
artistically
i feel very comfortable in saying that
the lego movie franchise has done the
best out of those but financially
only the first one was a real true
runaway success
you know um ninjago did okay
lego batman did decent but then lego
movie two underperformed
and warner brothers realized
it's not that this is uh unprofitable
but we were expecting more of this than
we're gonna get
and then dc that started all imploding
initially because they put so much faith
in zack snyder whose vision was
let's go with divisive um
and then
you know all the mess with justice
league
and there clearly wasn't a very good
plan in place and then everything harry
potter related well yeah the initial
problem that the first two fantastic
beasts movies aren't very good this and
the second one's worse than the first
one but neither of them were very good
they weren't whipping up the um
the fervor that warner brothers wanted
uh and that's even before we get into
the problems of
her royal turfness
so
that's initially
what caused the problem
uh what went wrong after that
was that
at t bought warner brothers
and that was a disaster for warner
brothers
most of the worst decisions made in the
last four years are a direct result of
the att buyout either because of
directives that came down from a t
or
um
as things that were done because they
were believed that they would better
placate a t
a t
uh
gutted
um dc comics it's a shell now
they
um put all the demand all of this
massive pressure onto hbo max which led
to some
decisions related to that which really
bit them in the butt
like
it's i do think ultimately that
the merger with discovery is going to be
better for
um
it is going to be better for warner
brothers than being owned by att was i
do believe that that said mergers tend
to bring restructures
and they tend to bring changing of the
guard so
things are going to be rocky and shaky
and turbulent
for a while before they hopefully settle
down
uh brogan you'll forgive me
there are lots and lots and lots
of resources
in lots of places
detailing um
what miss uh
what ms rowling has said
um i'm not going to
go over it here
and
uh i would prefer it not to become a
a big topic in the chat
so
there are
lots of resources some particularly good
videos uh jimmy dodger made a very good
video
back in june of 2020
when
you know sort of the the essay that
confirmed
um
everyone's worst fears
came out
and there's uh ones done by just gender
i've done multiple there are resources
that you can look to
so i i would i would ask to not have it
uh turn
into
the subject of the chat which i see it's
doing anyway
and yeah
gozer i'm going to apologize that um
you're having to deal
with this many people
then again this just has kind of been
the vibe of the day
anyways
all right
thank you very much from uh little steve
verritt
or ver vert fair i don't know a little
steve hey there hope you're doing well
ezra miller once again got arrested
today yep saw that do you think this is
the final nail in the coffin for the
flash i don't
know
i i honestly
don't know
um
[Music]
because like the
the situation is getting worse but i
don't know if it's going to get as bad
as it would need to get for them to
either fully shelve the project or
reshoot the whole dang thing
warner brothers is not going to bring
ezra miller back anytime soon if ever
like that's that's a done deal that's a
that ship sailed
um
when you spoke to jason hey gallery did
it bother you that he made the we want
to hire the best people argument when
you asked him about representation uh
initially it did but that was also part
of why we had the supplementary thing in
that interview where i talked to him
later and he
explained some things about demographics
in the uk which
i had never taken into account before
and it's helpful for me to know
uh supreme omega thank you again
i always wondered why in the 90s dc
focused so much on legacy heroes like
wally kyle tim drake star girl etc
uh was it all about chasing
new trends i don't
think it was i think what it was it was
um it was almost kind of a natural
extension of the crisis on infinite
earths because the initial idea behind
doing crisis on infinite earths was to
simplify and streamline
things
um
so
another way to do that after you've
simplified them you got rid of the
multiverse and theoretically simplified
timelines
is
to have the mantle of major heroes taken
on by
younger characters who don't carry
as much baggage at least as that hero so
that readers at the time could feel like
they were
properly engaged with
um
a more complete run of a hero as they
got to see
you know wally become
the flash or uh or tim drake become
robin it could feel like theirs
and not that i think that this was in
dc's mind but not in a way dissimilar
from how cert people have their doctor
and doctor who
i think that was part of the general
mentality behind why they did it and i'm
actually really annoyed that dc has
backpedaled erased or otherwise uh
ignored
a lot of its legacy characters
basically because jeff johns doesn't
like legacies which is stupid legacies
was one of the things that actually
separated dc from marvel marvel didn't
really do legacy characters they've got
they've got a handful
dc used to have a lot and it there's a
lot of unique storytelling potential
that
eventually along the way they just
decided no we're
we're not going to do that anymore
have you heard of the podcast
sardonicast i have not
um i have uh
i i i
do not even have the time for the
podcast i do listen to
oh uh
okay
something like that i'm sorry thank you
very much for the super chat i have no
questions or comments i just like to
hear you talk and butcher your name
apparently so
uh there you go
favorite pizza topic
sorry i thought you could do with a
lighter question uh favorite pizza is uh
mood dependent
go-to lately has been
broccoli onion garlic and tomato
a small pizza because i'll eat the whole
thing
uh
my favorite candy i don't really have a
a definite favorite
uh who do you think the next actor
actress uh will be besides senator
alexander to take on the role of the
doctor on the 14th season of doctor who
i have no idea
i'm just i'm i'm not a good person to
ask casting
questions about it's just i'm bad at it
do you think that in thor love and
thunder jane foster's cancer will be
caused by her body having been inhabited
by the ether
they might do that i'd rather they
didn't because you know
cancer just happens
it's a thing it doesn't need a mystical
explanation
but we'll see john vinyls thank you
again for the super chat i appreciate
that immensely honestly it's amazing how
much rowling has torpedoed all the
goodwill she ever had
people really loved harry potter in 2015
now it's like it's forgotten
and now it will likely be forgotten
forever in 50 years it's hard to
it's hard to tell there there are a
frustratingly
large number of
people who really just want to put their
head in the sand
and like if you want to put your head in
the sand in so far as
um you know just not engaging with it at
all like the fandom the work whatever
that's one thing
but
like i'm not gonna name names on this
but like for instance my partner liz you
know she's a school librarian
and
at librarian conferences she's
seen and talked with librarians who like
still have these massive displays up for
harry potter and their school libraries
and they're like oh but the kids love it
i'm like the kids will love something
else if you give them something else
there are other options so like they
they're
while the um love of harry potter is
certainly nowhere near as universal as
it once was and i do feel in general
it's declining partly because of the
turf stuff but also partly because the
fantastic beasts movies have been crap
so i can't imagine that helps
but
a lot of and here's the thing i've said
before and i will stand by this
it's
okay for individuals to continue to
cling on to this if it means something
to you if it enhances your life to keep
it around
in the form of the movies the books your
merchandise whatever fine
that's it's honestly fine
but i get really frustrated
with things like parents and teachers
continuing to
push it as something that
you know for for their kids or their
students because
that's you promoting it to a whole new
generation who
frankly deserves better
so
you know if if it matters to you that's
fine
but
stop promoting it and stop trying to get
other people to
support it
just please
hey angus thank you so much for the
super chat thoughts on the seed devils i
seem to use a lot of practical
animatronics as opposed to cgi uh well
obviously the whole suit was was um
you know was
a uh a practical suit the funny thing is
though when i went back and like double
checked something when i was uh when i
was editing the review
um
i actually don't think they had
animatronics like for the for the neck
movements looking at it more closely i
think they just use like photoshop
effects to like make certain bits bulge
because
watching it again like the way that it
did it it wasn't it wasn't bad it worked
actually but i'm like that's not
actually part of the suit that's an
after effect
it still did kind of work but
excuse me
do you prefer scrambled eggs or eggs
sunny-side up
uh scrambled usually
do you ever ish
do you ever wish we found out
about this after she died tolkien
believed screwed up stuff but we don't
care because he died 60 years ago i mean
that's
i don't know how to engage with that
question because
if she could truly keep a lid on it
um
until she passed away presumably of
national natural causes so like in
i don't know 40 50 years or whatever
that would also mean in theory that she
was never
actively campaigning
for these things she was never writing
essays about it
and if that was the case
yeah
it would be different
because
while i don't think it's good for anyone
to hold those kinds of thoughts or
feelings like in their heart
i care less if you're not acting on it
i wish you didn't like i have
family who
i know think some things that i really
wish they didn't
but none of them go out and like join
protests and campaign
on behalf of these things that they
think
and while it doesn't make it completely
okay like it does lessen the blow
so
you know for whatever that's worth i
suppose
uh i missed a whole bunch of chat bits
where i was where i was tagged so i
apologize for that
um supreme omega how come marvel never
did legacy heroes until recently with
miles and kamala in the 2010s is it
because their shared universe is much
younger than dc
um well their universe is less
complicated
um and marvel also never really went in
for the sidekicks which is the other
major source of legacy
characters um
so i think those were the two main
reasons that it happened a lot more at
dc than
uh than at marvel
my thing with rowling is that she
purposely took the comfort and
relatability
uh
that the trans community found within
the series away
and it was a 100 malicious i
this is not me trying to give credit
to
jk rowling uh for anything i've actually
got got a timer set for the discord
reminder gozer thank you though
um
but what i will say is i don't think
it was ever part
of a plan to deliberately remove
um
a sense of community from trans people
i think she just didn't care i think she
wanted to say what she believed and
didn't care
um i don't think it was
malice in that sense
um
[Music]
but that is the practical outcome
of what happened and it's very
frustrating
um
about
just um
now i've lost the thought
sorry
i i'm not high energy today so this is
where this is where we're at
um
but anyways uh meg hey meg i'm glad you
made it who's our moderator we've got
gozer handling moderation today
carowinds not feeling well so
um but we've got gozer on that question
have you considered doing more reactions
uh stuff other than trailers because
there's a video series i like called
what happened by matt mcmuscle that goes
over game development i actually watch
what happened
i don't watch a lot of his other stuff
because i actually don't like a lot of
his other stuff
but i do like what happened
um i'm not uh in the market right now
for adding any new styles of content
just because i'm backed up
on trying to get
work done just with the stuff that i've
got
um
the thing the thing about mac mcmuscles
and
actually most youtubers of his size
is that they
um pay people to do their editing
so you know he does he does the research
he does the scripting
he records the the voice work but
somebody else edits and edit is the time
sync and i can't afford to hire an
editor
so
have i ever seen little witch academia
nope never heard of it
uh
if doctor who was ever to do a crossover
with another franchise
uh what do you think would work or be
interesting
again that's i'm not a good person to
ask that i don't find crossovers that
interesting 99 times out of a hundred
so
am i gonna do a sonic 2 review
maybe eventually once it's on streaming
i'm not in any rush
uh
what is your most uncharacteristic
show you enjoy a show that people
wouldn't expect you to enjoy um
i don't know maybe shit's creek
given that i don't like sitcoms very
much
that might not be the uh the most
uncharacteristic but it's what's leaping
to mind
appreciate your live stream tonight
always love listening to you really
enjoy your podcast stay awesome vera
uh way hot dog from toronto oh thank you
very much for that i appreciate it
today's your 48th birthday well happy
birthday uh knit and crochet tiger
uh thoughts on hunter and the owl house
um
i haven't seen the latest episodes of
owl house
i've only seen what's out on disney plus
so
none at a present
um
uh
did i what did i watch dawson's creek
growing up no
no i didn't
ugh
doctor who plus farscape i mean like
there's fun
i'm sure
but
crossovers just think
if they weren't originally intended
um
you know to exist in the same universe
just crossovers just they're not really
my jam
ever heard of money heist might be your
bag give me your love of heist i feel
like that name sounds familiar
uh but i'm drawing a blanket
it only occurred to me the other day the
circumstances of rimmer's dalliance with
yvonne magruder is very problematic oh
yeah
oh yeah like red dwarf
for a comedy series a lot of red dwarf
stuff has aged pretty well
uh the yvonne magruder stuff
uh which is referenced in
early series of
uh
of radorf that
oh dear that uh
that yeah that that didn't age well
at all
uh
[Music]
is the donald house the disney plus
thing in the first place or at least i
thought second season was exclusive to
disney plus
no no it is on the disney channel then
shows up on disney plus later
sorry hang on
i was trying to do this like
surreptitiously but then
yeah
there we go
you're not properly relaxing until you
take off your belt
all right why why am i
am i getting messages sorry hang on
all right i'll deal with that later
uh am i worried about disney canning the
owl house special because of what dana
taran said they won't they know how bad
it will look that's the thing disney is
very image conscious right now and they
are
walking on eggshells and they know it
they won't do that
they will go through with what was
planned
uh are there any movies or tv shows that
you think have not aged well yeah most
of them
i mean most entertainment doesn't
uh
doesn't age well
belt isn't that the the bra line i'm
don't i very wear i very rarely i very
rarely wear bras so
uh
everyone keeps asking me about our flag
means death i've only seen the first
episode
it didn't grab me and i have not had the
time to watch more like i don't i don't
know if you people appreciate how buried
in work i am
all the time like all the time
all the time
money heist basic pitch a group of
robbers take over the mint in spain and
force hostages to print them money it's
also spanish
interesting
uh
thorn she caught the rusty smidge
the what oh whoever catches the rusty
smidge automatically wins the game
but that's stupid that invalidates all
our hard work
magic sports are dumb yeah but they're
all like this
i never realized how problematic the
ending of idiot slander was until i
watched your video and that episode was
filmed on my old street yeah
like it
that episode man that is
i don't have hbo max so i can't watch
our flag means death i do have it but
like
time
angus thank you very much you have
reviewed kinder and i think have
resurrection of the dogs but not snake
dance as three key tegan stories
thoughts on a review ahead of return or
does it need a commission um
i can try and get it in uh
before
the next uh special comes out
i'll i'll try and like i'll try and do
one
featuring tegan and one featuring um
ace
before
the um
before the next special
centenary is a word that just slides off
my brain i just keep forgetting what it
is and how to say it
uh
love getting on late and seeing an owl
house reference first thing
hoot
uh
hoot house hootie hooting
i do i do love hootie
hello
isn't there anyone there i'm on the
floor
it's cold
oh that voice that horrible horrible
voice
uh
idiots lantern does fiction need to stop
telling us we need to
uh make up with our [ __ ] parents
um
fiction needs to stop framing the idea
of forgiveness of family as an
obligation or an inherent nobility
i would never say that any one specific
person is beyond forgiveness or beyond
ever getting better but that is
something that the people in their life
will
make the determination of what does or
doesn't qualify as being enough for them
to let that person back in their life
what i cannot stand
is the general blanket notion of
well you have to give them another
chance their
your father your mother your brother
sister kid even
if somebody is truly that damaging and
truly that toxic
no you're not obligated
and like i i say this as someone who has
had
connections and
um
and
people within my family or families uh
to people who matter to me i've i've
i've seen
people get to the point where they have
to just walk away and stay that way
and the times that i've seen that they
were right to do so
and anyone who's ever going to be like
well you should have given them another
chance because it's your whatever the
relation is
no
screw you
and so anything that presents it
as a
as an uncomplicated unnuanced thing can
uh
can go to hell
okay meg yeah
if if you need to if you need to get
some rest that's fine thank you for
stopping by i do appreciate it
i have been reviewing moon knight uh
zeldheim but that's been on the break
room of geeks which is the subsidiary
channel that's actually where most of my
review material that isn't doctor who uh
goes
[Music]
that is my alert to check the discord
back in a minute reminder that the
uh council of geeks discord is a patreon
exclusive perk so if you go to
patreon.com council of geek and support
at the two dollar level or higher gets
you access to the discord which includes
a channel specifically for asking me
questions that will be addressed on the
uh live streams and it's the only other
way to guarantee it other than doing
super chats so
let's see what we got
let's tell you this when i commissioned
that culture
book review but i forgot a few months
ago i found out
uh why the culture is called okay so
this is in regards to the book series by
e m banks
uh it's a reference to a play from nazi
germany where soldier characters said
uh when i hear culture
i reach for my gun culture this context
meaning philosophy
literature art etc basically thinking
about stuff basically banks called it
the culture
because he meant it to be the embodiment
of everything fascists would hate does
that change how you feel about the
series at all um
it doesn't change anything
any of my thoughts on my opinions of
what i've read
it does
um
give me a frankly higher opinion of
banks and the headspace with which he
approached
his concept
because honestly anybody who's going to
approach
a creative project from the perspective
of
what could i do that would most piss off
a nazi you have my support
i that is a solid way to approach
anything that you care to write
um
so can i ask regarding babylon 5 for
people not on the pod what are your
initial feelings of the series okay uh
for anyone who's not listening to the
council of geeks
podcast feed and is not therefore
listening to the jump gate podcast that
i do with jesse gender going through
babylon 5 which i have not watched
before
um my thoughts so far
i
like and enjoy
the
politics and philosophical aspects
while i understand it was pretty good
for the time
that time being 1993 1994 for how far
into the series i am so far
um the effects are often wonky
some of the
specific character beats are outdated or
haven't aged well uh garibaldi's ticking
me off semi-regularly at this point but
i can see all the seeds of stuff that
like i definitely want to see more of
that and from what i understand of the
show it's what it largely focuses on and
that is the politics the philosophical
impasses and those kinds of ideas so
um overall i'm enjoying it i'm not in
love with it but it's also early days so
we'll see
and with that i return to the chat
thank you so much oh we got more super
chats john vinyl's full song for hoodie
in the stage musical version of the owl
house
uh
can't think of a good hoodie quote all
of a sudden
to find the answer you must seek solve
my riddle within a week
ow
okay okay
we went into the forest jeez
ow
uh another one from john vinyls thank
you so much is steven universe better
than idiots lantern by the way if so
how
um
that's
that's see i don't i never felt like
stevie universe
was ever making the case you have to
forgive them because they're family it
was coming at it from the opposite angle
because he had a very idealized
um
version of his mother in his head which
wasn't his fault that's what was fed to
him by the gems and by his father
so
you know when he learned that she wasn't
all that
it was it was less about you have to
forgive your parents the awful thing
because they're your parents and it was
more about
your parents
aren't perfect
and may have done stuff that make you
deeply uncomfortable
how will you
handle that how will you adjust
for that
um so i i'm not sure the comparison
is warranted at least not not in my mind
and not how i see them
um
presented
if that makes sense
cara thank you very much hey vera last
uh essay finish tonight so i can stay
kind of late tonight did you raid my
rate rate rage much at anything on
doctor who sunday it wasn't anything
worth raging about it was okay
like i had fun
i liked the vibe it was clunky didn't
really work but
yeah
ah
question have you considered doing a
cosplay of the character rugel
berenstein from king of fighters because
i think you could rock it i
am not familiar with that character so
i'm going to say that no i've not
considered it
[Music]
excuse me
uh
babylon five great moments plots long uh
hours and scripts but it is definitely
more than some of its parts interested
in the reboot i think that got shelved
last i heard
what's my favorite feature film from a24
i don't know how many of a24s films i've
actually seen i want to see men i've
seen the trailer for that but i like um
i like alex garland so i gotta see what
like i need to get a list of their
releases
i have to check that
a24
um filmography
list of a24 films how many of these have
i seen
um
nope nope nope nope nope nope oh yeah
okay so i've seen under the skin
oh that movie's unsettling holy crap
so that's one
um
nope nope nope x oh x machina oh so
they've been working with alex garland
okay cool x marking as that one was very
good
so there's two
um
uh oh room was them oh that one was good
also
yeah yeah okay it's pretty solid green
room was okay i feel like that one's
overpraised a bit
and even the ones that like i haven't
seen the ones that i'm recognizing i'm
like that did look interesting
um
just checking see what else we got
nope haven't seen it haven't seen it
haven't seen it
nope wanted to see it
i haven't seen it haven't seen i haven't
seen it haven't seen it
nope
nope
nope nope nope nope nope i've not seen a
lot of the films from this studio
yeah i think i've
might have only seen the two
uh hold on i'm into the 2020s i wanted
to see that but i missed it
uh i got to find out if that's streaming
anywhere yet
uh
nope i haven't seen it
nope i haven't seen it yeah
i've seen very few a24 movies
i should see more a lot of them did look
um
really interesting
everything everywhere all at once is
bonkers i love it so much i want to see
that but it's not playing anywhere near
me
uh anyone did anyone else like the
artists i love that movie i never saw
that one
uh fun fact about the wolf spider he has
organic webbing like toby but he also
has organic spider lights coming out of
his back like iron spider
finally he's uh
inter-dimensional
threat
huh
see when i think about multi-limb
spider-man i immediately think of
doppelganger who i kind of prefer
see under the skin i think under the
skin
it didn't go off the rails but it lost
some of its power uh in the third act
but i'll tell you man that's that
that movie
unsettled me
then there's one
very specific scene in that movie that
deeply
deeply unsettled me like i kind of felt
empty for the rest of the day
that yeah
uh what do you think of fans defending
bad creative decisions in media with any
universe reasons as
uh to why like i know people who justify
baine's voice he had his lips and nose
ripped off like yeah i hate that
if something if if i if i or anybody
ever says
um
you know this doesn't work
and i don't enjoy it
or
this rubbed me the wrong way or gives an
opinion you can't counteract that with
an in-universe explanation
like
me saying bane's voice is stupid and
laughable and it makes it so i can't
take the character seriously defending
with well well the reason he sounds like
that is because it doesn't matter why
the end result is still the same
in universe justifications don't fix
this
ah
first room and the tardis you want to
see apart from the console room i want
to see the swimming pool i bet it's
weird
oh hint at the scene the the scene in
excuse me and under the skin that
really shook me was it was the beach
scene
if you've seen the movie you should know
what i'm talking about
um but that
oh
man
yeah
speaking of spider-man villains bring uh
man spider into the mcu you cowards well
like the mcu it's it's it's a weird
legal thing because sony has the
movie rights to spider-man and they're
only really
uh sharing
that character himself with the greater
mcu and the rest of it's just under sony
so it's it's weird
um
have you seen the cast percy jackson for
disney plus series uh i think i'd seen
that it happened
like i'm not following that at all i
never read those books so i don't
i don't mean to sound dismissive but i
don't care
oh
i want to give you a general take re
enjoying art versus supporting the
artist if not it's fine it's been a long
week um
i don't have a short version of that
i've done
lengthy videos already
um
short version you can't separate the
artist from the art and
just in a in a
plain
factual sense
good art bad art it is disrespectful to
the art to the artists and it is
disrespectful to art in general to
pretend that art exists in a vacuum and
is not the
result of the decisions made by a human
being with specific thoughts and
feelings and beliefs
that's what art is it is an extension
and expression of the artist now that
said i'm also a death of the author
person so if you have an interpretation
of a piece of art that doesn't match
with what the artist intended screw them
they don't get to say how you experience
their art that having been said
my
my thing with
partaking in the work of
problematic artists my main thing is
don't
financially or
um influence levels
give open
support to people
who
are either actively causing harm or are
unrepentant about the harm that they
have caused
so
when somebody's already dead like
lovecraft it was a racist piece of
garbage
um
i think it is important to know that
about him insofar as understanding how
that impacted some of his work
but you don't have to just engage with
it because he can't hurt anybody anymore
but with somebody like
rowling
or
uh roman polanski
or woody allen
or kevin spacey
you know that they're still around they
they either still are or they could
cause active harm or they are absolutely
unrepentant about the harm that they've
caused and sometimes there's just an ick
factor sometimes what you know about an
artist just makes you go
regardless of
you know anything else
i assume you saw tom the shadow's review
of aaron lewis's am i the only one and
shook your head at the very idea of a
guy from vermont bitching about
confederates that's your removals i am a
fan of todd in the shadows i did see
that and yes i am not i don't love the
fact that aaron lewis
is from vermont i don't love that at all
in fact if he dislikes it so much
and he wants to pretend like he's a
country singer move to the south you
jackass
maybe he does live down there now i
don't
know screw that guy
do you think the mcu will come part at
any point in the next few years or will
it just keep going from strength to
strength i think there's a third option
i think
the mcu will gradually decline it will
gradually see diminishing returns
it's
it's too well established with too many
um
[Music]
you know aspects and elements to just
suddenly collapse out of nowhere like
even if a
if an mcu movie bombed like right now
probably their biggest flop is eternals
but
everyone's just moving on but even if
like
let's just say for the sake of argument
four four love and thunder
bombs at the box office
it's a huge loss
that is not automatically going to
destabilize the entire mcu
there's all this other stuff going on
and a lot of it while it shares the
universe is fairly independent of each
other
so i that doesn't necessarily mean go
from strength to strength
i think eventually people will just
start to tire of it
and i actually think
that ultimately what will happen
is it will largely become the domain of
disney plus i think there will always be
enough interest in the mcu to maintain
to have it be worth doing
um
things like disney plus series
but it may eventually
not be worth producing as many big scale
movies as they do but that's uh that's
an eventuality
uh a24 is heredity and the witch right
yep that's them
you caught up on keep on the age of
wonderbeast yet nope only uh only
finished season one i'm waiting for the
kiddo to come back so we can keep going
uh and i am going to be wrapping it up
here soon
uh
supreme omega thank you so much uh how
come comic mj is hard to adapt
faithfully to other media the concept is
simple characteristic part of a girl who
hides her pain with a sense of humor
i think
i think
i don't think it's that she's difficult
to adapt faithfully i think there's a
fear of baggage that comes with the
tropes that she kind of embodies and
that's not to say there's no way to do
it well i think you absolutely could but
i think
there's a lot of
uh pitfalls with trying to do
the party girl you know as as your
romantic lead it's not impossible but i
think what we've run into is that
it's not uncommon for
uh adapters to just go well why don't we
just do something completely different
why don't we just do that instead rather
than try and figure out how to make this
work
uh in a way that doesn't make us look
like
misogynistic jackasses
uh oh angie
dudes thank you very much for the
rainbow
that was wonderful thank you
i'm from liverpool i was wondering if
you learned anything about liverpool or
were confused about anything uh from
liverpool based on what was shown in
doctor who
um
i know that's where the beatles are from
i don't know a ton about liverpool and i
can't say that uh
something like flux left me with a ton
of questions about liverpool any more
than anywhere else that i don't really
know in the uk
uh i'm sure it's a lovely place
uh
but i think
yeah i think i'm gonna wrap it up
so um
about some of the original dudley moore
arthur films never saw him
but yes uh if you could
hit the like
uh that would be appreciated
i hope everybody has a good day good
rest of the day good rest of the week
um i gotta finish
editing saturday's video get that up for
early access for the patreon supporters
and uh
just maybe think about relaxing
i won't do it
but i'll think about it
so thank you very much for tuning in
everybody
and
please remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
has adjourned
my cavity